[Musique]
la sécurité sociale lance la première
édition de la Semaine de l'emploi à la
sécu cette semaine du 2 au 6 octobre et
à la cave des Yvelines nous avons fait
le choix d'organiser un forum des
métiers demain mardi 3 octobre de 9h à
14h ici à Versailles objectif est double
pour nous c'est de faire découvrir la
pluralité de nos métiers au plus grand
nombre et également de répondre à un
enjeu de recrutement qui est fort
[Musique]
nous avons une pluralité de métier à
l'acadés Yvelines lors du forum nous
allons présenter cinq grandes familles
de métiers donc les métiers des
prestations et de la relation de service
aux allocataires les métiers de la
relation de service aux familles et aux
partenaires les métiers de la sécurité
de la sécurité financière les métiers de
la gestion interne donc des fonctions
support et aussi les métiers du
management
[Musique]
au-delà des diplômes nous ce qu'on va
rechercher ce sont des compétences c'est
aussi une motivation une capacité
d'évolution nous formons aussi nos
collaborateurs donc vraiment nous
recherchons des profils très diversifiés
y compris nous recrutons des alternants
et des jeunes diplômés
lors de la matinée les participants
pourront venir rencontrer des
collaborateurs de la cave des Yvelines
pour échanger sur leur expérience leur
vécu ils pourront également rencontrer
l'équipe RH sur le process de
recrutement et pourquoi pas déposer leur
CV
pour s'inscrire à ce forum c'est très
simple il suffit d'aller sur le site
caf.fr à la rubrique ma Caf
l'inscription n'est pas obligatoire mais
elle est recommandée pour une meilleure
organisation du forum puisque lorsque
vous vous inscrivez vous pouvez
également choisir le créneau souhaité
donc soit de 9 heures à 11h de 11h à
12h30 à 14h
[Musique]